all right guys so my job here is to
basically make a bunch of viral videos
and I'm trying to come up with a video
idea recently Sara right over there what
she shined foil and it got like seven
million views it was insane so I've been
doing some research and I found that
people have been making dirt balls for a
while they've been shining dirt looks
pretty cool so uh let's go shine some
balls this video shouldn't be too hard
because basically I mean all I need is
dirt let's go get some dirt
I don't know where to find dirt in New
York got dirt I found there brother
these dirt is more like cement so
damnit
I got an idea we're gonna go to Central
Park they've got a lot of dirt there
[Music]
why are you spitting why are you
spinning
you got to spin around me now so before
I go to Central Park and I need to get
some stuff from a hardware store I'm
gonna get a shovel and a bucket for my
dirt we got a bucket got my shovel and
some sandpaper so I can polish my dirty
balls okay and some sandpaper so I can
polish my balls some sandpaper so that I
can say I'm up sand and some sandpaper
second polish my dirty book oh I see the
whole thing you think they have
something that I could buy like an
outfit so I don't get my clothes dirty
okay so I made at the Central Park
trying to get some dirt oh my god it's
so hot all right so I got my dirt time
to go back to the office and make these
dental floss all right welcome to my
kitchen this is where we're gonna be
polishing the dirt falls it's gonna be
super simple I got my bowl add a little
bit of dirt and then I'm gonna add a
little bit of water so I can turn it
into a ball and then I'm gonna sandpaper
it so that it can become shiny let's do
it feels pretty dry it's like kind of
flaking on me so I'm gonna add a little
bit of water make sure the water is nice
and like a little bit cold I'm just
making this up as they go you're gonna
pour it in there nice like you're just
watering plants
super easy my advice was eyeball the
water I already poured way too much
water because
Wow okay okay so it's to wait I'm gonna
add some more dirt to it there we go
now it feels good right now this ball is
a little bit too wet so I'm gonna try it
we're gonna put it in the microwave and
it should be good all right where's the
microwave
where's the microwave I'm just
eyeballing this I don't really know what
I'm doing but it's a dirt ball how hard
can it be
dude it's actually really high have you
ever felt hot before
it's steaming okay so here is the dry
dirt ball it actually looks pretty good
but it still needs to get sanded I got
all the liquid out of it but I needed to
get shiny Sarah really really sanded
that tinfoil ball I'm just gonna say it
real hard ready
[Music]
I have no idea what I'm doing and I
don't know how I'm gonna finish this
video why just watch this video okay
watch the original video
[Music]
okay so the videos on the AARP YouTube
page let's check it out
you don't want to have too much waters
you want to shoot for a better
consistency right gently sprinkle some
of this dirt over the curve of your
thumb here's a good surface to kind of
drag along the surface okay all right I
get it we're gonna have to go back to
the store
I need something to sift the dirt with
so I found this window screen and it has
double sifting and last but not least
got the basin first thing you have to do
is sift the dirt I'm not gonna pretend I
know why you have to but you just have
to sift the dirt so let's do that I'm
actually having a good time just rubbing
dirt dude there's a worm there's a
freaking worm look it's a dead worm now
I kind of know want to sift any more so
I'm going to check right now how much
dirt I've sifted and if I need to keep
sifting
[Music]
that's a lot of like because pretty that
looks it looks like sand
half of the dirt is gonna be used to
make the ball and the other half of the
dirt is gonna be dried dirt that you
just sprinkle on on the top and you make
that the outer layer so it's strong
right now this looks pretty good right
he said you want to get all the air out
of the ball so right now what you're
doing is you're just kind of compressing
it just like the tinfoil ball you just
kind of compress that's what it's
looking like right now it feels pretty
heavy pretty dense the next step was to
just sprinkle dirt and rub it in with
your thumbs all around and they said
that they spent a little bit of time
doing that it's really got to be Drive
for this part
the only thing I'm worried about is this
dirt was a little bit wet because it
rained in New York yesterday and the
video we watched the guy uses purely dry
dry dirt like it flakes onto the ball
I'm gonna leave this outside so that it
can dry I'm gonna try again with dry
dirt so I'll see you guys in over 24
hours all right so it's been over 24
hours I'm gonna go outside and check on
the dirt and see if it's dry
Oh
okay so the dirt looks like sand now it
looks nothing like it did yesterday
we're gonna do steps two and three again
so first you take a little bit of it and
you pour it on the ball and then you rub
it in with your hands this is a very
different sensation because now I feel
like I'm creating a new layer so you're
gonna have to do this for a while it's
not like you spray a little bit on the
ball and then move on you probably have
to spend what like 20-30 minutes just
rubbing it in creating this layer and I
think I'm gonna go on to the final step
now which is just rubbing my hand in the
dirt just getting some like dust residue
and then tapping it on the ball I think
what it does is just kind of fills in
the holes any tiny little holes all the
particles will just settle in okay we
got some shoe polish cloth and I'm gonna
see what happens if I rub it with shoe
polish across and then when you review
it when you take the cloth off it should
be super shiny
so shiny that Cisco is that avocado my
rock it's a dirt ball I made this out of
dirt wow it looks so clean I love it is
this really dirt yeah it smells like
funky Park does it really no I would
sell it for like $300 if you want to buy
it for $300 I'm also throwing this shirt
I'll cut a piece of my hair and lifetime
guarantee if you call right now it's
only three payments of $9.99
wait that's not enough three payments of
$99.99 that's hard to say I took dirt
and I turned it into something shiny and
incredible and that means that you can
just take anything in this world and
make it beautiful that's dirt No
[Music]